hi hello
um
so
just to introduce him uh lissandra is
machine learning engineer talking phase
where he's involved in many open source
projects and his aim is to make machine
learning accessible to everyone by
developing powerful tools with a very
simple api
and today is going to talk to us about
the urging phase app as a means to
collaborate on and share on machine
learning projects
need me
right adding the video to the stream
hey everybody welcome to this talk about
the hugging face hub
i'm lysander i'm part of the open source
team at hugging face and i'm super happy
to be here to present to you all
everything we've built over the last few
years
so we'll get straight to the point and
we'll start with the three main aspects
of the hugging phase hub
so these are models data sets and spaces
we'll take a look at the first two in
detail and have a small introduction of
the third one because merve is going to
present the third one the spaces in her
standalone talk
so let's first take a look at the model
hub
the model hub hosts a wide variety of
different models it acts as a platform
for hosting and sharing models
and actually we just passed the 20 000
public models milestone this weekend
which is pretty exciting
and these models these 20 000 public
models are trained on a lot of different
tasks
so we have a lot of filtering options on
the left if we go take a look at the
tasks category there is a split for the
domains the fields
the natural language processing models
come first with many different tasks
available and in other fields there are
the audio and computer vision domains
with hereto quite a lot of different
tasks
the models available here are not
necessarily from the transformers
library the model hub is agnostic to the
library
so while there are a lot of transformer
models there are also models from other
libraries such as flare
tim speech brain scikit-learn and many
others
any model can be uploaded so even models
that are in pure pi torch or pure
tensorflow or any other frameworks can
be uploaded here and offered to the
community
other filtering options include data
sets to filter out models trained on
specific data sets
languages which is particularly
important for nlp tasks while there are
a lot of english based models where very
proud to also host thousands of models
in other languages
it's also possible to filter out by
license so that you make sure to only
see the models which will fit to what
you're working on
and finally the last filter helps filter
out models compatible with some of the
training or inference tools we have at
hugging face such as auto nlp
or infinity
so let's check out what a model looks
like on the front end on the web
interface
when clicking on a model you're
redirected to the model card of the
model
on the right you'll see the api widget
with which you can play to get a feel of
the model
on the left you'll see the model card i
just mentioned
which can be seen as the documentation
of the model
this should contain the model's
description alongside any elements that
would help understanding what the model
was trained for and how it should be
used
this should contain code samples for
usability
mentions of the data sets on which the
model was trained the hyper parameter
during training used and it should
highlight areas where the model should
perform well as well as areas where it
wouldn't perform as well
we strongly recommend mentioning the
potential issues with the model for
example regarding potential biases and
limitations
all right so now that we've taken a look
at the model hub and before we
understand how to contribute a model to
the model hub we're going to take a look
at the data sets hub
similarly to the model hub on the left
we'll see a few categories to filter out
data sets
there's the very general task categories
first which you can complete using the
most specific tasks filtering option
you'll then get a few other filtering
options like languages sizes and
licenses
when clicking on a data set you'll be
facing this super cool page with a lot
of information about the data set
the first thing we'll see on the page is
the brand new data set preview which
allows you to navigate the data set and
get a feel for the format and content of
that data set
this works with text but also with
images for example here with mnist
you can take a look at the different
splits for example the training and
testing split here
and coming back to the glue dataset page
you'll see some additional information
which may be useful similarly to the
model card there is the data set card
which is as important and really goes a
long way to explain what is the data set
made of and how it should be used
additionally on the right you'll find
all the models which were trained on
this data set
cool so now that we've taken a look at
both the model hub and the data set hub
the final third big component of the
hugging face hub are the spaces spaces
are a super good way to demo your
machine learning projects they're
customizable and deserve a talk on their
own which is great as motave will deep
will dive deep in spaces with you in a
bit
okay now that we understand about the
three core components let's understand
how we can work with them and
collaborate using them
so what's really cool with the hub is
that all of those are basically get
repositories models data sets and spaces
are all get repositories which you can
clone to your machine
and there are several ways to work on
them the first one is through the
hugging face website which is very
straightforward but is a bit limiting
the second one is through the open
source libraries themselves for example
if working with transformers or data
sets you'll see some loading and saving
utilities which will work directly with
the hub i won't dive into them here as
lewis will do so in his upcoming talk
here we'll study the third way which is
using the hugging phase hub python
library
this is what is used under the hood in
by all third party libraries and it
provides a super simple api which sits
right on top of git and get lfs to
provide custom utility methods so it's
exactly like using git in your command
line except it's made for model and data
set and spaces
repositories with a few useful utility
functions
so let's start with a simple use case we
have this model which is a really cool
model from the transformers library it
can perform some super fancy text
generation in the computational
linguistics style
let me show you the model first
i start by looking at the files which
are in the model
here i see that i have both the
tokenizer and module files files inside
the folder
i load the tokenizer and i load the
model to have them in memory directly
now that i'm ready the first thing i
want to do is to create a model
repository on the hugging face hub
i do so using the create repo function
from the hogging face hub python library
i call it with the mycool archive model
parameter
which means that i'll be creating that
repository under my namespace which is
lysander
i can check that it was correctly
created by checking out the web
interface
navigating to my profile page and boom
the model is indeed here if i check the
content however i see that it is empty
which is normal since we just created it
now that the model repository is created
i want something to handle it
for that i used the repository object
i instantiate it with two parameters
the first one
local folder is the folder i'll be using
locally to store the clone of the
repository
the second parameter is the id of the
repository which i'm cloning
nice
now that the repository is cloned i
should have a local folder containing
the remote files
if i list the content i see that i only
have the get files but nothing else
that's normal since we just created the
repository as we have just seen on the
web interface
we'll now save the model n tokenizer and
the local folder to have the files
directly inside it we could also have
just moved the files in it from the
previous folder that we had but it
wouldn't have made for such a cool demo
right so if we list the files in the
folder again great we have all the files
that we have just saved we're ready for
the push
we now follow the usual git workflow we
first stage the files using the get add
method we input a special parameter
which is the auto lfs track parameter
this does some lfs magic under the hood
where it will automatically track large
files that would be otherwise rejected
it's not always necessary but it doesn't
hurt to run it
we then commit the files and we push
those files
since i sped up that part 20 times it
ended up being super fast which is
fantastic
nice we have successfully committed our
model
if we go back over to the web interface
we can see that there's now an inference
api widget
so we can try it out directly on the
website and make sure that the model
works exactly as we expect it to
nice we have successfully committed our
model we'll take a quick look at doing
the same with a data set which isn't
very different
so i have my data set saved on disk i'll
import it using the load from disk
method
i load my super cool data set in memory
and i use the two same methods i used
before
here i add another argument which is the
repo type argument i'm essentially
telling the methods that they're handing
a different report type they're handling
a dataset rather than a model
now that the repository is created i can
take a look at it in the web interface
it's empty once again but we're going to
fill it really soon
we save the data set using the 2par k
method to save it as a parquet file
using the traditional git add commit and
push and we're good to go
okay that's it for the model and dataset
hub and how to use them
we'll explore further ways to handle
your models data sets and spaces and the
other talks by my team members and in
the course of course
thank you for listening to the talk and
i'm really looking forward to seeing all
of your cool projects you're going to do
during this week and i really look
forward to working with you all
great thanks for talk lisandra it's
super nice
um thank you most enthusiasm i've ever
seen about the mnist dataset so yeah i'm
very very enthusiastic about like model
cars dataset cards
even the model here with computational
linguistics made me excited so you know
cool so a couple of questions that come
to mind is um when we're using the hub
to to share say models for example some
of these models that we have now are
getting quite large is there kind of a
limit to what i can push to the hub can
it be
ppt3
oh that's that's a good question so uh
yeah as you said the model sizes have
been uh getting bigger and bigger and uh
in the past
uh we've had a few issues with managing
such big models uh but actually like the
infrastructure is getting more robust to
do so like a good example of a huge it's
not a model but it's a it's a data set
which i believe is the multilingual
version of c4 which weighs 19 terabytes
it actually lives on the hub right now
and there is no uh and actually the um
big science effort
uh
which is this big effort with uh more
than 500 scientists working on the
creating a very big artifact uses the
hub
as a means to store
intermediary weights so these weights
can end up being very very large
um
and the hub
is a is a cool place to to use it's not
necessarily the best place according to
what you're trying to do but for
most use cases it's definitely a place
to be considered to store very large
weights
awesome great
and another question that um i've often
wondered is like you know the hugging
face hub um is one of several hubs that
exist in this space so we have the
tensorflow hub there's also a pi torch
hub
and i i know there's also some other
data set hubs we're just wondering like
what do you think i like the kind of
sort of differences like sort of
philosophically between these different
hubs
that's a good question um so i think
there's a
there are quite big differences in
between each of those hubs
um with the uh with the model and the
data set up what we're really trying to
achieve
is uh we're trying to have this agnostic
platform where people can share their
models
uh agnostically to the library so it may
be in python maybe in tensorflow maybe
in jax or even many other libraries like
like seen in the videos we have support
for at an nlp we have support for space
you have support for many others i
believe there were some efforts in julia
also recently so we're just being very
open
to any contributions that might be
helpful to the community as long as it's
open it's fine um
and then like if you compare it to the
uh to the pi torch hub it's so it's a
bit different as
uh the pirate which hub shares uh
something a bit different with the
weight but also code to run directly
inside
the python runtime whereas we mostly
share just weights
uh so then it's up to you to get your
code running uh as you want inspect it
as you want whereas with the power touch
hub it's uh it's just you know slightly
different and not as a raw i'd say uh
it's still super super cool and uh and
has a lot of uh
uh it's very
useful i would say but just serves a
different purpose than our hub serves
and i think the two are very
complementary
yeah exactly
and and i think it's that's the key
thing that like it's not necessarily a
question of either or it kind of really
depends on on your use case and also
maybe if you're for example using the
tensorflow hub you get some extra
features like tensorflow extended and
you know this you know if you if that's
what you're working in it makes sense to
use the best tools for that
yeah absolutely and like for the for the
hugging phase hub what we're really
reaching for
is a is for this central platform where
everybody can feel free to share
their models as much as they want they
can just store as many checkpoints they
want
for example we
with the recent trainer changes we
really encourage people to push their uh
intermediary checkpoints to the hub as a
standalone commits so for example if you
do a full training run using the trainer
you have the option to not only push the
final model for use but you can also
push every intermediate checkpoints and
where this
becomes really really cool is that as we
can as we have just seen in the video
when i play with the model at the end of
pushing it you cannot actually just do
that during training so if you're
training a model you can just
add different points of the training
like every thousand epochs or every 100
epochs or every 10 epochs you choose you
can just check and see if the
generations are better with the uh
according to the task you're doing of
course but you can just check if the
uh performance of your model is getting
better with like very uh intuitively
awesome awesome
yeah and maybe another question that um
i've heard a lot from people in the
community is like you know suppose i'm
working in like a framework that maybe
isn't supported yet so i know that right
now we have transformers and we've also
got spacey and alan nlp but like you
know maybe i'm like a researcher who has
like a kind of let's say maybe more
niche
library
is it still possible for me to share my
models on the hub
absolutely that's a great question
so the way we do things is that we
encourage people to have upstream and
downstream supports in their library
which means the ability to just use
models from the hub in their library or
to push modules to github
but if you're having a very niche
library which doesn't necessarily have a
lot of users or doesn't necessarily have
all these uh serialization mechanisms
maybe you're not too interested in that
and you just want something that works
for yourself and so with the hugging
face hub python library we offer this
kind of
front hand to the hub
which isn't this uh web ui but it's a
python library which you can use for uh
like to download models who cache them
in your to cache them locally to prevent
likely downloading a lot of
identical files uh and also some
upstream
management tools to manage your
repositories on the hub to manage your
files that are getting uploaded so
either either of these two options
should work
according to what you're really trying
to achieve if it's making it easier for
your users or if it's just for yourself
to upload models to your repository
awesome so we've also got just had a
question that's come in um in the thread
so
this is a really important question
which is you know some data sets have
some licensing issues or maybe they're
just copyright material um is it okay to
still share these on the hub
right so that's that's a good question
usually it's it's best to think of those
as a case
basis according to the license
um so when data sets are shared with a
very permissive license um
then they can of course be shared it's
important to always
keep a link to the license of the data
set under which it was shared so there's
some utilities on the hub to actively
show which license is the data set under
for some more complex
licenses for example some data sets
require
specific licenses where you would have
to share your name your email to have
access to the data set
and here it's a bit different
where when sharing the data set you
should try as
well you should
as much as possible try to respect the
license as otherwise it's just not
legally shareable
cool and um maybe maybe a more personal
question so you know right now we have
um
quite a few different uh positions
available in the open source team um and
maybe it'd be cool to sort of tell
people a little bit about what is it
like being like a day in the life in the
open source team at hugging face and you
know maybe for yourself you lead the
team so what does that also involve
yeah thank you for thank you for asking
i think that's uh that's an interesting
question that we get a lot um
something i like to say is that even
though we
were very very open with uh like hiring
a lot of people we're really looking for
uh generally the same skills that any
machine learning engineer would have
um so basically uh yeah when you think
of a machine engineer or data engineer
uh it's basically the same skills but
the job is actually very different
because when working at hugging face
you're not going well you can but most
of the time you're not going to spend
time working on a
model or a data set and trying to have
the best performance trying to have the
best security try to do your own
training pipeline what you're actually
going to do is instead
work on providing the tools to do that
better so you need to have the skills
because you need to understand uh
all of that
um activity all of that work uh but that
in the end at the end of the day what
you're really going to build is a tool
to make it easier for people like you uh
to just do that
and so this uh this also comes with a a
few uh skills which maybe are not too
traditional for a machine learning
engineer
engineers this comes with communication
styles skills sorry because you need to
manage this open source community you
need to be
very open to uh disagreements because uh
of course there's always going to be
some open source repositories
um and you need to just basically uh
be very open for collaboration uh at
hugging face we really strive for
collaboration as our main
ethics where we think the more people we
have collaborating on project
the better and the more inclusive the
resulting projects may be
so right now we've
just passed the thousand contributors on
the transformers library which is super
exciting super exciting milestone and uh
i think we're really going to strive for
uh making it as accessible as possible
to for people to contribute
uh to the library not only use the
letters
awesome thanks a lot for all that
information and and i was just going to
maybe a follow-up thing would be like
you know if i'm interested in one of the
roles in the open source team
um probably the thing that like really
helps if you want to sort of stand out
from the pack is to have some open
source experience yourself and a great
way to start is actually just to start
looking at the issues on say the hugging
face libraries you can check out the
data sets transformers i can face hub
library and this is often a great way of
kind of developing a kind of
an unusual relationship with the
maintainers um
i find this was i think in my case
personally my very first contribution
was to the datasets library and this was
where i interacted with consuan and some
others and i don't know it's a nice way
of getting a feeling of like what it
would be like also to maybe work here
and so my suggestion would be if you
have the time
um to take a look at that
yeah exactly and it's it's also a bit
peculiar i don't think everybody likes
the community aspect of it
to interact with community contributors
to review prs to look at issues to solve
tickets i don't think that's something
for everybody so it's a very very good
way to just
check and see if open source is
something that is is interesting to you
definitely
cool so then one last question which is
uh similar to mats
um
also you're heavily involved in the
transformers library
what is on the horizon we've now got
vision we've got audio and nlp
what's next
and that's that's a great question we're
really going to push forward with the
multi-field aspect of the transformers
library so up to now we've been mostly
focusing on nlp but as you've said now
we're also
um
quite active in the speech and vision
fields we're going to push those aspects
further we're actively working on
improving our speech
models right now with some language
models capabilities uh same for vision
where we're really going to have
we're really striving for
transformers to be
a very very useful
tool in the entire computer vision stack
on top of that there are also other cool
things that are coming up
for example silva has been working on a
super cool aspect of the hub integration
where right now you can just push models
and tokenizers to the hub what silva has
been working on is this is the ability
to push
model code tokenizer code directly to
the hub
and so for example if you have your
standard bird model uh it's uh
and the let's say you're just changing a
tiny thing in the way the attention is
computed um it can be a bit uh of a
hassle to just open a pr to the hugging
face
library because you know you need all
those tests to work you need all those
all this documentation to work and maybe
what you're trying to solve is like
maybe you're not actually trying to
get it contributed you're just trying
things out but you still want other
people to use it so the best way to do
that right now is just to fork the repo
push your changes and then ask that
people to to use that fork instead but
with silvan's work you can actually just
push the updated model files the updated
token has refused to the hub and then as
soon as anybody wants to use them
they can just say okay i trust the files
in that repository let me just use them
and it will use these files alongside
the model weights
awesome so that means i can do like from
pre-trained and it just works
yeah basically you will still need to
specify that you're okay with loading a
remote code from that repository because
otherwise it's a big security risk but
as long as you say that um that's
perfect
awesome
great so i think we're now ready for our
next speaker is that right silvan
all right one last question so can we
use git tags in the hub for model
version
absolutely absolutely basically all
repositories and on the hub are
traditional get repost so anything that
works with a git repose will work on the
hub